il y avait jolin à la page 123 une
souche virulente aussi mortelle qu'est
mollahs est aussi contagieuse que la
grippe se propagera tel rapidement au
monde entier sans une réponse sanitaire
et peut être mise au point alors bien
sûr la mortalité due coronavirus n'est
pas la même que celle de mbola mais ça
contribue à l'idée est la même elle est
encore d'actualité
je dirais même plus il est encore plus
d'actualité
avec ma fille nous avons acheté cette
maison voilà une très zen d'années parce
que nous avons anticipé le fait que un
effondrement général à systémique et
globale du monde puisse avoir lieu
douze ont ouvert les années 2025 2030 je
ne suis pas à 5 ans près en tout ça fait
7 hectares le tas de bois c'est du
douglas a été coupée voilà quelques
semaines on va le laisser là pour
l'instant on n'a pas le temps de le
transporter près de la maison
voici notre ami ge est bien éteint irish
cob avec une très belle robe et qui
permettrait en tout cas où on aurait des
difficultés de mobilité de tracts et une
calèche ou même d'être monté et si
jamais il y avait une rupture
d'approvisionnement en eau bien vous
voyez ici que nous avons une pompe à
bras que j'actionne à une faune adrar
qui est branché sur un puits et qui
permet d'avoir de l'eau que l'on peut
évidemment à la fois filtrée et bouillir
ou telle manière qu être accrue sur
potable voilà un autre stock de bois qui
est en cours de constitution
donc ce n'est pas un problème pour nous
en tout cas le bois de chauffage car
nous avons le manière autosuffisante des
quantités qui nous permettent de tenir
même plusieurs hivers
[Musique]
nous sommes peut-être à la veille d'une
cause majeure d'un effondrement plus
large puisque ce serait simplement le
premier facteur le premier domino qui
tomberaient c'est à dire une prise de
sanitaires qui va entraîner de toute
façon ça on en est sûr aussi maintenant
une crise on peut dire économique
financière bancaire et monétaire aussi
sinon plus forte encore que celle que
nous avions eu en 2008 et 2009 et par
conséquent le choc sur nos civilisations
sur le monde entier sera terrible flux
les morts seront nombreux et plus fort
sera le choc à la fois le choc
économique et politique mais aussi le
job psychologique
il faut absolument qu'ils aient une
solidarité organisée à l'échelon local
de telle manière qu'on tienne soins et
qu'on prenne soin les uns les uns des
autres qu'on s'aime d'une certaine
manière les uns et les autres de telle
manière que l'on fasse encore société et
qu'on ne tombe pas dans le nombrilisme
et la barbarie ou simplement l'égoïsme
en disant je m'en fous des eaux du
moment que moi j'ai mes rations de
survie
il ya donc une politique de solidarité
nationale mais de se lier terre
affective de suri tête de solidarité
psychologique qui peut être fait par des
activités communes même loin les uns des
autres les activités communes
grâce à l'internet qui marche encore
toute notre vie telle qu'on la vit
actuellement notamment en europe par
exemple mais c'est la même chose et lui
en australie ou même maintenant en chine
tient sur des camions et sur les
transports de marchandises et le service
les camions ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'il y ait des conducteurs il faut lier
les chauffeurs routiers
il faut qu'ils aient du pétrole alors si
jamais les chauffeurs routiers par
exemple dans la mesure où il ya le
confinement et où les stations service
sont ouvertes au point de vue de la
distribution d'essence mais elles n'ont
pas le droit de faire de la restauration
bon c'est la même chose pour les
restoroutes qu'on voyait jadis et qui
existe encore et bien ceci rend leur vie
encore plus pénible déjà qu'ils ont une
semaine assez assez difficile dans la
mesure où ils sont éloignés de leurs
proches et reviennent chez eux qu' une
fois par semaine
si en plus les conditions par exemple
alimentation ou d'hébergement sont
mauvais eh bien peut-être qu'un certain
nombre d'eux vont dire je ne veux pas à
vie dans ces conditions et donc je me
mets dans une sorte de droit de retrait
et à ce moment là il est possible
je ne sais pas si ça va arriver mais que
certains états peut être en france
fassent appel à des chauffeurs militaire
est réquisitionné semi remorque afin que
l'alimentation l'alimentation je dis
bien soit disponible partout en france
dans les supermarchés je ne cite pas de
mât ou même dans les commerces de détail
en ville si on n'a pas d'alimentation
les émeutes voir la barbarie n'est pas
loin je dis toujours je ne sais pas si
la phrase est apocryphe ou pas enfin
elle est bonne
que cherchent ils auraient dit la
différence entre la civilisation et la
barbarie
ces cinq repas il faut donc que chacun
d'entre nous en france en europe
puissent avoir accès à l'alimentation
une alimentation suffisamment variés et
6 et au besoin par des chauffeurs
militaires et les camions réquisitionnés
il faudra le faire à condition
évidemment qu'il n'y ait pas de rupture
de la chaîne d'approvisionnement
mondiale comme il peut y en avoir parce
que actuellement notre alimentation est
trop mondialisée c'est pour ça que dans
mes propositions politiques
le propos de relocaliser la production
alimentaire et d'avoir finalement des
denrées alimentaires qu'ils soient plus
végétal plus saisonnière est plus local
c'est les trois caractéristiques d'une
bonne alimentation et qui donc ils sont
pas du tout les caractéristiques
actuelles de ce convoi a dans l'est dans
les hypers surfaces dans les grandes
surfaces dans les hypermarchés
on voit qu'on a des fruits et légumes du
monde entier pendant toute l'année c'est
tout à fait scandaleux
il faut tenir compte de l'empreinte
écologique de l'empreinte carbone des
produits qui viennent de l'extérieur
actuellement dans les pays comme la
france cette empreinte nourriture cette
empreinte carbone de nos denrées
alimentaires est beaucoup trop forte il
faut donc relocaliser donc plus végétal
beaucoup moins de viande plus saisonnier
et plus local